taking you live now to a kabul where the
uh taliban spokesman is giving uh
statements
let's listen in afghanistan for the
first time enjoy
security and safety
our country is now providing all these
services
social economics
and his aide
they will be declared
muhammad
foreign
acting foreign minister
is the
internal minister
acting internal minister
[Music]
electricity and energy
[Music]
mohammed
foreign
naming new ministers that will form the
uh taliban uh government named a number
of ministries there um i understand we
have some english translation uh back
now so we will we'll go back and listen
in
[Music]
simple problem
is
in the rest of the ministry
need
and until we get into a
more stable situation
we will be acting
accurately and speedily to
have
the future administration in place
we do have clear policy
a clear policy god willing
and the next
the
other
ministers will be uh declared later on
and uh
finally we praise god
now i can answer questions of the
brothers journalists
are there no journalists
no press
french press
there was some protest this afternoon in
uh
this morning and this afternoon in kabul
and herrat
according to some reports there were
some
people journalists who were
beaten or arrested
during this process this protest so
would like to know what would you
confirm on that this arrest and why they
were arrested thank you very much
thank you very much
we
the
atmosphere is not
the right one and
[Music]
ministry of justice and the competent
authorities
we have to know in advance but
unfortunately brothers do make this
demonstrations
[Music]
foreign
okay so you've been listening there to
uh
the taliban spokesman addressing the
media there earlier he had announced uh
the names of a number of uh new
ministers uh to head up uh what will
form the new uh taliban uh government uh
something that uh
people have been waiting for for several
days now
um
and uh i understand we uh we have
english uh translation uh no no we don't
um
uh so
he then took some questions um
from journalists and was asked about the
protests uh that have been taking place
uh in uh recent uh
in recent days in which uh
uh this tuesday in fact taliban fighters
were seen firing shots into the air to
disperse
uh hundreds of people uh we're gonna go
back now
to the pressure because we have uh we
have translation in this translation
permanent ones but in the future
this will happen
we will of course in future
appoint people in a
fundamental and permanent
fashion then the ministers will be
acting within
the law and the legal framework
what
the
affairs
[Music]
as you said
the government we announced is an acting
government it is not the future and
permanent
government
and there has been
security
we also know some people do not have
enough experience to deal with
demonstrators
and i would like and hope that this is
left for the future so that it can be
dealt with
properly within
a
full-time government
and
now
we do not
allow people to
use the current situation in order to
cause trouble
the interference of pakistan
it has been
abandoned about for 20 years
we do not allow interference
we act with complete freedom and we were
able to fight
the countries of the world who were
occupying our country
from
the outset we thought the whole world
for the sake of islam and this country
god forbid they want to drive a wedge
between us and pakistan
we have sacrificed
and provided many
sacrifices in defense of this country
and the people of this country
[Music]
a government
[Music]
issue
that if some of those people are known
faces and familiar faces
who are in the government
then it would be a a
a government
that is
shared by everybody
other than that the government will not
be
sharing the power
we
need to be able to defend our country
and
we have been fighting kandahar
and we're not from one
tribe for example we do have people from
all different
ethnicities and from different
backgrounds
so we are a diverse
everybody yes
not from the
stone but
some of the people
you mentioned were talking about
different issues for 20
years and talking about uh
personal interests
allow
people
to speak on behalf of
turn it into a tribal thing we wanted a
comprehensive and fully functioning
government
everybody is a representative of this
country and thank god we don't have any
problem with the panchayat
we do have a lot of
resources
generally speaking
the panchayats are said to be the poor
ones
however some people live in caves and
live
and others have been
participating participating in previous
government who had
great wealth
so where were you from these people
foreign
[Music]
that there are demonstrations
and the way
taliban is dealing with the
demonstrators
is
harsh and they have been beating us up
and breaking our tools and equipment
if
they continue
dealing with the demonstrators
in this fashion so what would be the
result in the future
as you
said in the beginning
that these days you do not allow
demonstrators
from pashtun
because these people do not need
security and stability in the country
any exchanges or
battles
in afghanistan
bring back the
weapons you took because this is from
the bait and that belongs to the state
make sure that we
are in a situation that is
very critical
and we hope
that the press raised their voice but
in a proper manner
so our
some of our people do not have enough
experience to be able to deal properly
with the administrators
and
as i have said
and i say again
this period of time
we cannot allow demonstrations
my question is how
how do you think how many countries of
the world will support and recognize you
do all islamic countries
recognize your legitimacy
there are international
relations we and we want good relations
with old countries of the world
america
americans were engaged in the war and
they occupied our
country
however we still want uh bilateral
relationships
we do not
allow any country to interfere in our
affairs
this is
in this country we do our work and we
are responsible and we do not
wish any interference in our
work and interference in our government
and we do not allow and do not accept
that
either
we do not interfere in any other
country's affairs
and
we do not
allow and accept anyone to interfere in
our
affairs now or in the future
and we hope that all
countries of the world
recognize the legitimacy of our country
and the legitimacy of our islamic
regime
and nobody
would be able to allow to abuse our
country
thank you mr
this
situation as i mentioned
our relationship is good with all
the countries
of the world
we have good relationships and positive
relationships
because
countries of the world begin to have
good relationship with the islamic
state of
afghanistan
[Music]
[Music]
but when are you going to announce the
fourth
[Music]
[Music]
because the persons who want to live
afghanistan
diplomatic or other personnel must have
the right documents
in order
and they have to go through the exit
gate and the entry gate
as we have announced
through the
ministries that
we will be dealing
with the problems of flights as of
tomorrow
the ministries we have not announced and
we will announce that we'll be dealing
with this matter which is a women's
right
all right so we've just been listening
there uh to uh the uh taliban spokesman
zabihullah mujahid speaking to the media
they're announcing um
that
the the new ministers that will form the
taliban government taking pains though
uh to make clear that this was an acting
government not a future government and
that there were still several other
positions uh yet to be named uh he said
that uh muhammad hassan would lead the
government and hassan
would be the attacking with the acting
uh prime minister um charles stratford
is live for us in kabul he has been
listening uh to this uh with us as well
uh so charles uh
your thoughts uh on this
well very interesting that's going to
answer obviously a lot of questions of
you know millions of people here in
afghanistan
and around the world as to you know
the beginnings of what seems to be a
taliban administration i think it's fair
to say that a lot of the names that have
been mentioned that have been allocated
positions
are old faces um whether it be
i'll just name a few of them here
whether it be muhammad hassan the deputy
pm uh muhammad hassan rahmani he was the
deputy pm under the taliban leadership
in 1991.
muller baradar who
is is has been named
sorry the deputy pm
he has he was the chief political
officer
who participated in all those years of
negotiations in doha we understand that
he was
a top commander under mullah omar we
know that he was arrested in
in pakistan in 2010 and released by
order of the americans in 2018 in order
to start participating
in those negotiations in doha
other names mentioned mula yakub as
defence minister our acting defense
minister we should say
uh malia kube is the son of mullah omar
who was a top
military commander in the taliban and
also um vitally a dimension of suraj
hakarni as acting interior minister
somebody who is associated very much
part of the haqqani network a very
controversial figure a network that has
been blamed by the west for countless uh
bombings and terror acts but as i say
this is the beginnings this is an acting
government and it's going to be very
interesting to see how this develops
um all right sir we've got we've got to
leave the early stages we've got to
leave it there charles thanks for that
lots more reaction on this to come here
on al jazeera as the taliban begins
naming a new government stay with us
first